thanks for making me laugh i watched the
film last night and uh i i i had a blast
watching it it made me laugh a lot
ah dang man great news
uh so i wanna i think i wanna ask the
most important question right up front
um and it's for robert uh is there can
you just tell me what is the time period
that you allow people when when you
start filming a production to talk about
the wire with you is it like a six hour
block is it like the first day and then
like okay i got it we know i'm in the
wire or is it like you know whatever you
want to do
yeah it's a just a couple of minutes you
know i mean the show lives on and people
love it
and uh you know it's a hat tip and i'm
honored to be a part of it um
i haven't seen it since it ran
and you know i trust that people
are really attached to it for a big
reason and uh then we let it go because
you got to be in the now and um
i'm all about the now
yeah i love the show like everybody else
um but one of the things that's really
interesting about this film that i don't
think people will realize is you started
filming and then it just all of a sudden
had to shut down for covid and there was
like a big break what is it like being
part of a film that has like a five
month or six month break it was
interesting because you know people have
to you know everything is shut down so
you know you're gonna come back and do
it well you don't really know and the
the exciting news is when they say all
right
we figured this out or we haven't really
figured it out but we figured out uh a
solution of how we can operate
successfully and you know just taking
the test every other day
um uh staying in the hotel for the
duration of the shoot and and really
making sure we took the the measures of
safety to to be able to go out and be
able to give you guys this this awesome
film was uh was it was amazing and it
also being trapped in the hotel for so
long and then going a set and being able
to play we just had so much more
freedom in life so we we really brought
that to the screen is there anything
that you think might surprise people to
learn about the making of this film that
is very technical
you know um
there was just a lot a lot of uh
very precise
things you know cameras that were
brought in and
you know
shots were set up
um
that really
brought out more comedy than
i thought we were playing you know some
of the things i was like oh man is this
working and
in fact it works you know so it's
sometimes you have to get out of your
own way and let
uh the masters of the craft really do
their thing because they know what
they're doing and then my part is just
to you know show up and try to get to
110
um
but it's
it was a very technical movie in a lot
of ways with um from our horses the
horse riding our stuff with our stunts
with the my stunts with the animals and
and all of that um and
somehow it works you know so that's
where
clay's mastery comes in
and all the producers and directors they
they made this thing
really rise to uh to what you see i
already have to rap i'm just going to
say again thank you for making me laugh
i hope the film's a huge hit for you
guys
thank you collider